team
a man is known by the company he keeps a
company is known by the men it keeps
thomas watson senior
i just finished writing a really hard
email
someone on my team has been
underperforming and i just let her know
i'd be cutting back her hours
it kills me
she just gets the job done
but i don't want people at my company
who just get the job done
you shouldn't either
it's easy to fire someone who isn't
doing their job it's easy to fire
someone who keeps making big mistakes
but what do you do with the mediocre
people who just float by
fire them too
it's important because if your company
is filled with people who are mediocre
you won't have a company for very long
you're not going to do great work with
average people
average people also pull down the morale
the rest your team they bring down your
energy too and make you more average
you need motivated people who love their
job and want to pour everything they
have into the business
moving on is better for them too
let them be free and find something they
love doing instead of keeping them in a
role they aren't flourishing in
give them every opportunity to succeed
every single opportunity
but if they don't step up as an employee
you need to step up as a ceo and do the
right thing
short but sweet today folks i'm
frustrated and sad
it's never an easy decision but it's the
right one
believe